[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7
août loisirs merci de nous retrouver
pour votre numéro dédié à vos idées
sorties tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 25 mai ce dimanche 27 mai c'est
la fête des mères profité du week-end
pour créer vous même un cadeau fait
maison à offrir à votre maman de notre
rendez-vous junior mélanie potier nous
montrera comment réaliser ok les fleurs
en papier homonyme et compagnie c'est le
premier roman de béatrice bauchet une
histoire d' aventure avec un ton léger
et un humour fantaisistes l'auteur
donnera samedi 26 mai une séance de
dédicaces à versailles il sera avec nous
pour nous présenter son livre enfin
l'artisanat sera à l'honneur tout le
week end à rambouillet la bergerie
nationale accueillera une cinquantaine
d'exposants pour son salon des métiers
d'art une créatrice de chapeaux de
chevreuse y participent nous avons
découvert son activité alors que le
dernier star wars sur en solo est sorti
cette semaine vous pourrez vivre en vrai
des combats de sabre laser ce dimanche
27 mai l'académie de sabre laser de
voisins-le-bretonneux accueille le
premier tournoi national open des jeux
liés à l'univers de la saga seront
également proposées toute la journée
cédric giroud le fondateur de l'académie
nous avait parlé du programme lors de sa
venue dans notre journal
la semaine dernière il y aura une
convention lui dit qu'il a avec des jeux
liés à l'univers star wars des
cosplayeurs des animations
un orchestre de cuivres aussi qui sera
là à la fin de la journée et
parallèlement à ça donc le championnat
qui sera en place
et dans ce tournoi effectivement fait
des petites nouveautés c'est à dire que
pour le moment la fédération en actes et
du combat en individuel mais on essaie
développer ça avec effectivement du
combat en équipe qui est plus proche du
grandeur nature avec des gestuelles pour
lancer des programmes et celle qu'on
peut voir dans la saga star wars
et c'est en tout cas ce qui s'en
rapproche un peu plus un petit peu plus
oui du béton et des plaques de verre
comme supports photographiques depuis
une dizaine d'années caroline late
imagine des histoires urbaines
originaire de saint quentin en yvelines
l'artiste s'inspire en partie de
l'agglomération pour réaliser ses
oeuvres
une trentaine d'entre elles sont
exposées à la maison des bonheurs à
magny les hameaux jusqu'au 29 mai elle
c'est un travail sur un cycle sur la
construction et la déconstruction se
dire qu'on n'est pas arrêté dans une
époque dans un temps on a toujours
l'impression qu'on est enfermé dans
notre présent alors qu' il ya eu un
enchaînement de civilisation avant nous
et je pense que chaque civilisation
avait l'impression d'être enfermé dans
son présent alors que les choses se sont
déconstruite et reconstruite après donc
d'où l'intérêt de travailler sur la
ruine et sur la tracé sur l'idée de
mémoire puisqu'en fait
la ruine appelle forcément à la
reconstruction
[Musique]
ce dimanche 27 mai c'est la fête des
mères l'occasion de passer un moment et
d'offrir un petit cadeau à sa maman et
pourquoi pas le créez vous-mêmes mélanie
poquet à une idée à partager une idée
fleury manon varaldo pour les images le
27 mai approche à grands pas et pour
fêter ma maman j'ai décidé de lui offrir
des fleurs mais pas n'importe lesquels
des fleurs en papier et aujourd'hui on
va faire le modèle rouge
[Applaudissements]
pour commencer on va prendre le pot de
yaourt un peu de peinture
ensuite on va faire la tige bien sûr
alors moi ce sont des grands bâtons en
bois donc prennent plus longue je prends
la taille du pot je voudrais que ça
dépasse légèrement
[Musique]
ensuite le papier crépon donc bien sûr
moi j'ai décidé de faire des fleurs
rouges
on découpe une petite bande
on va faire des arrondis sur le papier
qui va nous permettre de faire des
pétales
ensuite je prends mon petit bateau un
petit bout de scotch qui va me permettre
de faire tenir la base de ma fleur et là
il m'a fort que gens roulent mais en
fronçant légèrement pour permettre de
former ma fleur j'ai fini de faire la
fleur il faut bien sûr le faire tenir
rien de plus simple un petit coucou de
scotch
on le fait ou le scotch à la base
légèrement en biais en enroulant
descendant jusqu'au bout de la tige
je n'ai plus qu'à la mettre dans le pot
de fleurs et d'en faire de plus en plus
pour faire un peu comme ça moi j'en ai
fait une autre un peu plus gros se
trouve plein de modèles sur internet
n'hésitez pas à vous taper fleurs en
papier crépon
voilà moi j'ai pour offrir ça à ma maman
et vous camille qu'est ce que vous allez
faire
un homme part en voyage avec une femme
qui porte le même nom que son
ex-compagne souvenez-vous ce fait divers
avait fait parler lui il ya quelques
années il a même inspiré une hauteur
pour un livre béatrice bausch est avec
nous pour nous parler de son premier
roman homonyme et compagnie paru en
février bonjour bonjour alors je le
disais l'instant donc homonyme et
compagnie c'est discorde en voyage un
peu particulier alors si un voyage qui
n'a pas exactement les effets prévus sur
les personnages d'abord parce que le
héros paul qui avaient réservé donc un
superbe voyage à travers l'europe pour
sa petite amie en fait se fait plaquer
avant le départ donc déjà le voyage n'a
plus tellement de raison d'être
mais il va partir quand même en faisant
profiter et toutes ses réservations à
une homonyme de son ex parce qu'il
s'agit quand même de traverser neuf pays
d'europe avec des réservations dans les
hôtels des billets d'avion donc c'est
pas rien et
une homonyme donc une nouvelle elodie va
partir avec lui seulement voilà quand on
vient de se faire larguer on est souvent
pas très en forme et lui qui voulait
voyager avec son petit ami n'est plus
tellement motivés donc il est même
complètement anéantie et la nouvelle
audi va lui tenir un peu compagnie alors
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué dans cette
histoire au point d'écrire dessus ou bah
en fait ce qui m'a titillé c'est que le
fait divers précisait que la personne
qui partait à l'homonyme en question
elle avait un fiancé jaloux et c'est ce
caractère jaloux qui qui a fait que je
vous y a quelque chose à faire là dessus
et que la jalousie en fait tu vas aller
jusqu'à provoquer une surveillance très
rapprochés des voyageurs et donner un
petit côté comique et burlesque à
l'ensemble de l'aventuré
alors justement comment est ce que vous
avez adapté ce roman que ce personnage
se fiancer était évoquée dans l'article
de presse qui parlait de cette histoire
mais du coup vous avez vraiment donner
plus d'importance à ce personnage voilà
comment est ce que vous avez adapté un
petit peu l'histoire à votre manière
c'est petit à petit en modelant ses
personnages ils ont pris un peu vie et
et je les voyais comme si comme si je
les connaissais alors c'est maintenant
on me demande souvent est ce que tu t'es
inspiré les quelqu'un tu connais non
mais je ne sais pas ils sont nés et puis
ce patrick qui est très jaloux il me il
m'amuse est parce qu il a un côté un
petit peu frimeur et en même temps il
n'a aucune confiance en sa fiancée et
du coup petit à petit j'avais
l'impression que les personnages vivait
puis moi je prenais des notes sur ce qui
leur arrivait et j'ai vraiment
l'impression d'avoir fait connaissance
avec quelques quelques amis qui ont
décoté touchant et qui sont très
attachants on a parlé rapidement du
style vous avez voulu adopter un ton
léger avec beaucoup d'humour
alors il ya l'humour oui mais comme
toutes les choses de la vie et derrière
il ya quand même un fond un petit peu
sérieux puisque j'évoque aussi les
différentes formes d'amour le coup de
foudre donc la confiance
l'engagement
donc on passe un bon moment parce que
parce que c'est plaisant mais il ya de
bonnes questions derrière un petit peu
de réflexion également vous avez
toujours été passionné de mots amoureuse
de la lecture vous êtes traductrice
d'ailleurs et donc ça a été un peu une
évidence pour vous de vous lancer dans
l'écriture
oui parce que
j'aime beaucoup les mots j'aime bien
lire j'aime bien
les bons mots et les belles lettres
et puis le fait d'être tenté par cette
ce fait divers et d'avoir envie de
raconter à mon tour une histoire j'adore
qu'on me raconter d'histoires mais
j'avais envie de raconter une cette fois
ci et donc c'est votre premier roman
dont vous aviez déjà écrit une pièce de
théâtre en 2011 oui j'avais écrit une
pièce de théâtre pour une troupe amateur
qui avaient envie de jouer une pièce sur
les problématiques des femmes mères
épouses un peu tous en même temps et
j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à l'écrire
pour pour la troupe est de voir que une
fois jouer ça avait un sens que c'était
drôle et que c'était sympathique ça m'a
donné envie de partager d'autres ont
d'autres choses dont vous vous serez
votre un autre mot de la fin on pourra
venir vous rencontrer samedi 26 maires à
versailles vous avez dédicacer votre
roman chez cap sur market une boutique
de créateurs
oui ce mythique des créateurs richaud à
versailles
de 10 heures à 19 heures je serai à la
boutique est ravi de rencontrer ceux qui
viendront
merci beaucoup béatrice bouche il est
revenu sur notre plateau donc rendez
vous chez capsule market à versailles
pour rencontrer l'auteur on va montrer
le livre effectivement on voit donc
homonyme et compagnie il est à commande
également sur internet et dans les
librairies et non du qu'on pourrait le
retrouver demain avec son auteur samedi
26 mai la capsule market merci encore
ici pour les mariages ou les cocktails
le chapeau est l'accessoire
indispensable pour parfaire une tenue et
la rendre plus chics ou élégante depuis
2012etvous une couture à s'élancer dans
la création de chapeaux et que sa marque
chloé danglade ces réalisations seront à
découvrir ce week end au salon des
métiers d'art organisé à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet nous l'avons
rencontré
bientôt ces cônes deviendront des
chapeaux evelyne couture à réalise elle
même à la main chacune des étapes
après avoir trempé le feutre dans la
gomme arabique et laisser sécher pendant
plusieurs heures place au moulage donc
le principe est de limbe beac hfo mid et
de passer le faire une fois ramolli le
feu reprend la forme du moule
une technique apprise auprès d'un
meilleur ouvrier de france depuis 2012
cette habitante de chevreuse créé ses
propres chapeau
j'ai une formation de fleuriste j'ai
tenu à un magasin de fleurs dans le
sud-ouest et ça m'a amené à créer des
bijoux de cheveux avec des fleurs
naturelles
j'ai eu une demande de plus en plus
fréquente de clientes qui voulaient
accessoirisé leur leurs tenues certaines
femmes voulaient être chapeauté ce qui
revient à la mode aussi de ce chat potté
soie sauvage toile de jouy dentelle de
calais amoureuse des belles matières
evelyne réalise plus de 300 chapeau par
an pour des cérémonies ou des cocktails
chacun d'eux est unique je travaille sur
mesure et là je je travaille donc dû
du sisal tressé qui est une matière
italienne sur lequel je fais une
décoration adapté à la à la robe de la
mariée
un savoir-faire à découvrir lors du
salon des métiers d'art à rambouillet la
créatrice exposera avec une cinquantaine
d'artisans les 26 et 27 mai ce samedi 26
mai ce sera la fête de l'enfance à
guyancourt des jeux des spectacles des
manèges et du sport une après midi
festive sur la thématique sport et corps
en mouvement c'est la 30e édition de ce
rendez vous devenu incontournable pour
la ville rendez vous au gymnase des
droits de l'homme dès 14 heures c'était
loisirs est maintenant terminé merci de
nous avoir suivis nous espérons que vous
avez fait le plein d'idées sorties
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro et je vous
souhaite un excellent week end
m
oh